here's your formal introduction is
Brandel Chamblee an integral part of the
golf channel's coverage next week of the
Open Championship and offering his
opinions reactions latest developments
throughout the week from Royal Birkdale
on Golf Central live from the open with
your hosts host rich Lerner you guys do
a great job on that show by the way love
watching them thank you is there
can you go too far when it comes to
giving an opinion in golf I think if you
you know if you keep it on topic you
know when I when people say you're
controversial I don't ever intend to be
controversial I you know I feel like I'm
just giving you an honest assessment I'm
paid for my opinions and by the time I
get to I always say I don't do research
to support my opinions I do research to
discover my opinion so by the time I've
done all my work I like well this is
clearly the way it is but if you don't
get into people and you just talk about
what they're doing on the golf course
then you know I don't I don't think so I
mean you can inevitably cross lines here
there and in a you know what this is
like live TV live radio whatever I mean
things happen but but there's a
fraternal field to golf that we're all
in it together and your former golfer
and you should be protecting us right
absolutely but you know you always it's
a tough line right you're always on that
when you first get out of golf when you
first get out of playing golf they're
all your friends and I remember right as
I got into TV I was playing with a
pretty big star I was playing a colonial
and he knew I was going into TV and he
said you know whatever you do don't be
like Johnny Miller and I was like what
do you mean honest and insightful the
best there is bright because even when I
played golf for a living you know Johnny
Miller not that I was on TV a lot with
the best of the players but occasionally
I'd get there and Johnny would tell the
world I choked or hit this shot or that
shot and drove my dad nuts and other
people nuts in the family I was like not
actually that was a pretty honest and
spot-on assessment of the way I played
the shot so you know I think most tour
players look they do what they do but
they don't understand what it is to be I
don't think they fully understand the
job and the job is to tell not 200
people what's going on you
speak for 200 people you speak for the
25 million people that play the game and
you're meant to tell them something
that's not obvious
you know what's obvious is well you hit
it short or to the right or to the left
or those are obvious you know trying to
tell people why someone hit it shorter
to the left or here you know the wife
pisses people off you know the what
everybody knows you know what he won
what he shot it's the why that that
tends to upset people because they're
like well who are you and why do you who
are you to tell us why you're like well
I don't know it's just my opinion but I
do think about it a lot but I think Golf
has always been one of those sports
prior to Johnny Miller even after Johnny
Miller that there was still some
trepidation about what you say and how
you say it because golfers are more
sensitive than any other athletes are
they more sensitive than any other
athletes they are absolutely because if
you if you are good enough to play
professional golf unlike every other
sport where you had a coach and when
you've missed a play you got criticized
you got yelled at you know you got
admonished but when you play golf for a
living and I mean I was a really good
golfer and all the way through junior
golf you are lauded you are applauded
you were written about you or nobody
criticizes you at all they open the door
for you you know you want a suite you
want a car you want free golf balls free
rounds of golf they're the nicest people
in the world you go to college you're on
scholarship you're recruited you know
they love you they logic we're going to
get you the best room in the dorm we're
going to get to this you get you you
never ever criticize then you turn pro
and you go into a club you get way we
can play you for free get the best table
at the restaurant you know nobody
criticizes you and then you get in the
final group of the US Open and you hit
just an awful golf shot and johnny was
like wow he took the club away too quick
he was quick in transition clearly the
situation is getting to him you know he
didn't think that one out that Johnny
did his job the players doing their job
and that's the way the game works best
and the folks at home are saying the
exact same things you know Johnny pretty
much says what people think and you know
Tour players because they've never been
criticized they were like hold on a
second how often have you been
confronted by a golfer pretty often
you know either through you know social
media you know they all have access to
has there been a heated one like
face-to-face
uh no not not so much but you know when
you're out on the range when I you know
I don't call a lot of golf a lot of live
golf so I'm not out on the range that
much but when I'm there you know you
know Ian Poulter you know a couple times
we walked by and sneer at me
wait you know just sneer you know as he
walks by I'm like you know I like
composure I like him a lot
you know I think I love watching you
play golf I love what he does in the
game of golf but you know I think if I
had the conversation with the unit like
least I had your job for 20 years but
you haven't had my job for five minutes
if you did you would understand that
there's nothing personal here I'm just
doing my job and I actually I don't
I mean 99% of the Tour players I love
them you know they're fun to watch I'm
talking about most of the time how good
they are what they do in charities all
the great things about them but the
human nature is I could sit here for an
hour and talk to you about how handsome
you are and how smart you are but if I
say by the way I don't like your shirt
that's all you remember you know a week
from now you're you know the Danites are
going to say he didn't like your shirt
you know that's crappy shirt yeah it's
just it's just you know it's just the
way it is by the way your Danites all
need work on their golf grips yeah baby
I was just dude they're there they're
overworked clearly you got to give him
some time off now see I'm going to be
Brandel Chamblee and I'm gonna say you
know that was interesting what you said
but they're the dance not the dance are
you made and he made a terrible mistake
and the dannemeyer or something like
that what the strangest thing you've
seen on the golf course is one I saw a
guy hit himself it didn't hit a tree but
he hit a golf ball and the ball didn't
hit anything else and hit him in the arm
and I still don't know how he did it but
when he did it you know immediately he
started flapping his arm like good
gracious you hit yourself
I saw I've seen players hit golf balls
straight up in the air come down and
then spin backwards so they lost yard I
don't lay lost yards have no idea how
they did well you are these pros that
are doing this well I
no these not these are programs I did
see Mark Brooks once who won a PGA
Championship I saw mark Brooks once
punching out of a tree or underneath the
trees hit a tree came back him around
the forehead you know I mean it happened
just like that you know I've seen I saw
two of the nicest guys I can't I'm
honest I can't say the names I wish I
could I saw two of the nicest guys in
golf
come toe-to-toe and almost fight in the
middle of a fairway once and I thought
you know literally if you asked a
hundred Tour Pros who are the two nicest
guys in golf so Matt Kuchar and who okay
so this is about 20 years 20 years 20 so
think twenty years ago ten twenties oh
and Ben Crenshaw you're on the right
track it wasn't Ben okay and and I saw
them come toe-to-toe nose-to-nose then
it bow up and I thought good gracious
I'm gonna have to get in the middle of
the these guys they ultimately didn't
throw punches but but yeah I've seen you
know I seen Tour players almost come to
blows guys drink did they drink when you
were playing yeah on the course
yeah I mean Jim Beam and Jack Daniels
were sports psychologists when I played
the tour that those were the sports
psychology so when they're playing oh no
not on the course no one no one drank no
I mean I I know of a couple of guys that
drank on the golf course just know
Feherty has talked about how ya know he
might exaggerate it a little bit but he
you know he's an alcoholic recovering
alcoholic yes he drank all night and it
affected his round but yes yes David
talked openly about that I I know of a
couple of guys that would go you know
had a couple of pops when they were out
on the golf course but by and large no I
mean there you don't want to lose your
job you know it's it's a hell of a job
if you can get it and are you penalized
like if they know I remember seeing guys
smoking cigarettes on the golf course
recently and then I wondered if the tour
is you know trying to discourage
baseball's telling managers don't be
smoking your cigarettes in the dugout
yeah I don't I don't see it so much
anymore but even the players that smoked
you know 20 30 40 years ago would do a
really good job of Ben Crenshaw smoked
but he did a great job of hiding and
palming the cigarette you know get our
nice smoke I think Arnie did
only did Arne spoke early in his career
he did some commercials for cigarettes
and it impacted the sales of the
cigarettes in a great way if you were a
golfer you wanted to smoke the same
cigarettes at Arnold Palmer did I say
that's how much times have changed right
I mean I don't see anybody smoking a
golf now
I still think Arnold Palmer was James
Bond before Jane Sean Connery as James
Bond I saw Arnie as something completely
different than he's like he was an
athlete you don't normally associate an
athlete to golf he was an athlete and
this was back in the 60s but he was an
athlete and he was the coolest athlete
the game had ever seen he was he was
cool he was absolutely James Bond you
know I I remember playing in the Open
Championship eons ago in 1987 and the
range is at Muirfield and the range was
absolutely chock-full of people warming
up and so I was down to my last five or
ten golf balls and I feel this you know
huge presence behind me and I just kind
of take a peek back there an Arnold
Palmer is standing right behind me
waiting for me to finish with his arms
crossed and I you know I think guy could
you please get behind anybody else but
me and I hit a couple of golf shots and
I kind of turned around it and I just
occurred to me that he was he had that
look on his face like like you would get
if you saw a dog trying to walk on his
hind legs I mean it's not so bad that
they can't hardly do it it's just you're
surprised of doing it at all and I
thought that's how he was looking at me
and you know I was like listen you you
go right ahead
and he goes oh no oh no please take your
time and I was like even he's judging
you yes yes of course you feel like you
are I'm like you've destroyed the
serenity here I'm going to leave and you
take over
he's Brandel Chamblee part of the open
coverage with NBC engulf the central
live from the open at Royal Birkdale
we'll come back a few things talked to
him about including playing overseas
also Tiger Woods Phil Mickelson and his
new caddie is there a story behind the
story there so we'll talk to a Brandel
Chamblee we'll continue coming up next
how is your golf swing by the way it's
not bad you know I think if yeah if we
went out and played I wouldn't embarrass
myself it's pretty good I'm playing a
practicing more now than I have in years
have this you know this this sort of
pipe dream I'm gonna go play a few
events I'm playing a practising like you
know every chance I get
you know my wife loves golf and she's
really really good at it do you want to
announce your comeback and yeah yeah I'm
announcing a comeback from someplace
I've never was but if we put all the
analysts and we had a tournament all the
golf analysts that's the great I think I
think Curt Byrum would hold his own okay
I think he's he's he plays a lot of golf
where was fouled oh and Monty oh okay
yes now that you've thrown Monty in
there I forgot about Monty would be the
number one line he would be Monty is
still yeah he still almost as good as he
was when he's playing the regular tour
Monty yeah Monty who's going to do you
guys make fun of Colin Montgomerie I
loved Colin you know Colin played golf
at Houston Baptist University when I
played at the University of Texas so
I've known Colin forever and when I
played on the tour I used to say that
the the people I enjoy playing with the
most or Frank Nobilo and Colin
Montgomerie
and it's you know and I also love
playing golf with David of all and it's
it's funny that now I work with them
because when I play golf with novel oh
we would talk from start to finish and
at the end of the round we had a great
time
none of us neither one of us would ever
break 75 paired together because we were
talking the whole day you know a novel
can talk about anything and I Colin
Montgomerie is the same way Colin
Montgomerie
you know a lot of people were getting
he's this petulant star but did you call
him miss dumpler no I did not
I bet that was parodies oh I think that
was parodies of his origination I think
originally I think parity and Colin had
you know sometime of contentious back
and forth we didn't see calling that
much but I remember once playing with
Colin at Honda and down you know South
Florida and we're on a tee we're waiting
for the group in front of us to get
through and he goes you know who do you
think he's the best player you've ever
played with you know and I guess he
thought I was going to say hell I guess
that's why he was asking the question
because at the time he was at the height
of his game you know and at that time
Steve Stricker was walking down a
fairway parallel to ours
I had just played a fair amount of golf
last Easter I play with him like in the
final group of the Canadian I never seen
anybody play as well as him this is
before Tiger okay right before Tiger and
I looked at I was like that guy right
there Steve Stricker and he goes could
call in and yell I call it kind of knew
me so he was like really it's not me it
sounds like no it is not you and it's
him that's that guy he was like well who
is like it Steve's here he's amazing I
had a couple of things rapid-fire here
is there a story behind the story with
Phil Mickelson and his caddy bones yeah
I think the story is doesn't matter how
good you are when you've been winning as
prolifically as phil has and you haven't
won since 2013 four years you know all
of a sudden nerves get frayed a little
bit that's my opinion you know I you
know they all mean I think I mean you
fire your caddy well every single player
caddy relationship has a shelf life you
know jack and angelo agrea eventually
came to an end you know this is 25 years
you know it's a it's a long time it's
it's bizarre you know it's it's so
bizarre to to look at Phil and not see
bones there it really is I mean the two
of those were the were the perfect
marriage you know and hey I guess I
guess divorce happened to me you know I
think they're both you know they're both
amazing people in their own right and
bones is very well respected I I'm
looking forward to doing TV with him you
know I think that's a terrific turn of a
page for for bones but I haven't heard
and I would have heard if there was a
story other than the fact that people
watched and they thought they were
linear back and forth were a little bit
more contentious but who knows you know
I mean bones will be on this show you
ask him I will yeah yeah all right uh
rapid-fire now Tigers competitive career
is over
yes competitive yes I think so you know
as playing career it's the it's the
perfect storm of things to rob you of
your game you know a bad back a only
change a golf swing problems with your
short game big problems with you short
game
those are competitive things and that's
the try
things to rob you of your career how do
you think he really got injured I think
probably working out would be my guess
you know I you know his combination of
things but I think they're working out
you know as he when he first came out on
on the tour he had the perfect body for
golf you know long limbs
Senya we had great speed and he traded
all that speed for strength and as he
got bigger his golf swing got shorter
and as it got shorter got flatter and as
it got shorter and flattery got quicker
and his change of direction became you
know speedy flashy instead of languid it
was salute vanity though where you you
want to look like an athlete you know
he's friends with Jordan right you want
to write he was very very thin read like
then yeah he was he if he still had that
shape absolutely I think he's no plan
when somebody said you know to me what
would you need to see from Tiger Woods
to know that he was on his way back I
would need to see 20 pounds thinner
Tiger Woods I would need to see send you
we Tiger Woods and then I think ok well
now you've got a chance to have a longer
golf swing and the longer golf swing
means your hands are more upright and
more upright means you've got more time
in transition and all those things are
going to allow him to just to play golf
without hurting himself and hit the ball
high in the air which is what he did
when he was at his best he worked out
with the Navy SEALs that's right yeah
jumping out of helicopters right up and
out you know he's doing you read these
stories and you think you know I mean
why would you do that I guess because
you can and it's exciting but when was
he did he hurt his knee jumping out of a
helicopter you know these are the things
I read you know so you know you read
them and you think good gracious you
know Hank Haney talked about some of
those in his book that he was training
with the with all these Special Forces
you know Bush talks about how Tiger
would go away for two or three weeks and
he'd come back and he would have a
bigger body he'd be bigger and you know
he'd go away for two weeks and he'd be
bigger than the last time you seen so he
couldn't really do all the things he was
doing previously and you know maybe it
was Tiger Woods thinking that you know
from a mental standpoint this gave him a
lot of strength from
physical standpoint he felt like it gave
him a strength maybe from an
intimidation standpoint him standing
there you look he was imposing when you
stood next to him oh yeah very imposing
a very intimidating guy you look at how
much he intimidated the cost of playing
with Tiger Woods you know on Saturday
ideally at that point you're meant to be
playing the same you get paired on
Saturday it costs almost four shots to
get pair with Tiger Woods so everybody
say I want to get pair with Tiger Woods
I'm like no you don't all right
the top three guys said Royal Birkdale
will be who Sergio Garcia John ROM and
Dustin Johnson
give me the sneaky pick though Kevin
Kisner is a sneaky pick you know he's
twenty fourth or fifth in the world
nobody you know nobody's talking about
him but he is he's bulletproof and you
know the golf course there has a way of
sort of divining out the best player in
the world you look at the players at one
there these are the best player in the
world or a player that's about to be one
of the best players in the world and
I've got great respect for Kevin Kisner
John Rondo looked great the Irish Open
on ROM is that player that comes along
and you think you know all you want to
see in the game of golf is a great
talent and tenacity but then you want to
see somebody that's not spoiled by
success that doesn't doesn't get you
know a little complacent you know
doesn't that euphoria of having one
doesn't linger until you know the next
day and it's over and that was the big
part of what made Tiger Woods Tiger
Woods and John ROM looks like that type
of player Brandel Chamblee
part of the it says an integral part of
Golf Channel's coverage next week at the
open that means I won't sleep offering
his opinions and reactions ladies
developments there throughout the week
at Royal Birkdale on golf central live
from the open we appreciate you stopping
by it's great to see again thanks for
all your contributions to the show
whenever we've called no more than more
than not you're there for us absolutely
it's it's a pleasure and I think you
have an untapped resource right here
looking around you when you guys finish
at noon you could sell tickets for tours
of this place it was the greatest man
cave I've ever seen
Smith's moats Smithsonian is a four-bit
I could imagine there is contrarian and
I want to thank the Danette there you go
right you can at Dennis for
golf lessons before we came on right
during the break the live look in
Brandel will unleash his golf swing if
you're watching on DirecTV the audience
network we're going to be the analyst
for him we're going to be brutally
honest with you Brando that's coming up
next
[Music]
let me see how you do under pressure
flag yeah so we have a target out there
oh just hit it straight there's a line
now today I got off the peak of the
mountain I see a winner of the way
what's tournament of you in the Canadian
Open this is a short list six my staff
just one waiter very rare that's it a
Canadian Open family thank you for the
open track very much thank you thank you
thank you try to keep it down y'all
better hold on to something
[Music]
okay
badass all the way down the middle I'm
interline by five feet okay as I hit it
three usual and I find that hard to
believe
2003 season no see
can you beat a Brandel Chamblee that's
right now on your shoes with a hat I'm
sorry we'll go in yes let's do huh I
don't get us very well and it certainly
don't do well under press exactly this
is too huge it drives a glance to me I
could tell you that now 130 you can't
eat him if you want to now I'm a winner
of nothing and I light please welcome to
the office various magic all right
who sits gonna fall short Oh who says
you're bad under pressure is 17 Holly
shot hey well solid IQ in my back hair
oh you're going to do is going to drop
solid job thank you alright coming back
that's the most pressure I've been on a
long time that's Jack you can't Ram
assembly yes what the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience